this man has symptoms of a disease that
has been declared a national disaster in
Malawi he is weak and has been brought
to this Health Center in blantire to be
treated for cholera
Crispin muliva brought his sick wife
here several days ago and in time she's
now recovering
when I returned home I will insist on my
family's hygiene my wife must cover food
properly the food must be well cooked I
will see to it that they have soap at
home for daily hand washing
more than 1 000 people have died in
Malawi in the last one year
more are coming to facilities like this
to get help health workers here say this
outbreak of Cholera is a crisis the
modality is a bit reduced because we are
admitting at risks like 10 patients per
day so compared to previous ones people
in villages in communities they have to
understand that cholera is still here
and they have to come to hospital
earlier so that they should minimize and
also reduce pressure to those people
that are working in the hospitals
the outbreak started in March during the
rainy season and has spread to different
parts of the country Health officials
have struggled to vaccinate everyone
oral vaccines have run out we are still
at high risk from the coldera went by
the numbers of course they are slightly
going down but still we are getting over
500 cases on a daily basis which what is
some to us and even the number of people
who are dying on a daily basis you get
maybe 10 15 20 which is still a wedding
factor for us
such outbreaks happen often in Malawi
but this is the worst on records the
disease is spread by contaminated food
water and poor hygiene
while it is easy to treat untreated it
can kill within hours
health workers are warning people about
the importance of keeping their homes
neighborhoods and markets clean and
they're hoping that message gets across
Catherine soy Al Jazeera